[Applaudissements]
malebranche un disciple de descartes
affirmait lorsqu'il battait un animal
que l'écrit qu'il poussait n'avait rien
à voir avec la douleur que c'était juste
un dysfonctionnement dans ses rouages
il ya trois siècles à peine préval et la
théorie de l'animal machine et
contrairement à ce que vous pensiez
monsieur descartes et bien les animaux
sont des êtres vivants sensible sans
qu'ils amendent senti en même c'est quoi
un animal sans tian et bien les anglo
saxons utilise cet adjectif pour
désigner le fait que les animaux
terrestres et aquatiques comme nous ont
des perceptions des désirs une volonté
des buts qui leur sont propres qu'ils
éprouvent des émotions des sensations
agréables désagréable qu'ils ressentent
la souffrance et la terreur qu'ils
tentent d'éviter désespérément parce
qu'ils tiennent à leur vie je suis
avocate et pendant plus de trente ans eh
bien j'ai exercé le droit de la famille
pendant plus de trente ans et j'ai
défendu les humains et bien aujourd'hui
j'ai décidé de mettre ma compétence au
service de ceux qui n'ont pas la parole
au service des animaux
ce n'est pas une question de sensiblerie
exacerbée parce qu'en fait pour moi
c'est avant tout une question de justice
justice pour les animaux et lorsque je
vois un animal je ne vois pas une chose
mignonne où horrible d'ailleurs je vois
un individu alors ma spécialité c'est le
droit de l'animal
qu'est ce que c'est les douanes animal
assez simple c'est l'ensemble des règles
juridiques qui sont impliqués nos
animaux alors comme en france et pas de
code des droits de l'animal
eh bien on les trouve éparpillés un peu
partout alors on trouve en code pénal
dans le code rural dans le code civil
et puis dans le code de l'environnement
il existe des règles favorable aux
animaux ou par le protection animale
mais il existe aussi des règles
défavorable et elles sont même
majoritaires c'est vous donner un seul
exemple parce qu'il date de la semaine
dernière on a autorisé l'euthanasie de
plus de 100 singes macaques de java sais
pas si vous avez entendu parler
en fait il était dans une sorte de zone
de réserve et au motif d'un problème
sanitaire est bien plus de 100 macaques
ont été euthanasiés voilà un exemple de
droit défavorable aux animaux alors un
petit peu d'histoire du droit de
l'animal ou plutôt de la protection
animale
parce qu'à la naissance du code civil
napoléonien en 1804 eh bien il
n'existait aucune règle de protection
des animaux
les seules règles qui existait des
règles défavorable il ya eu cinq étapes
importantes en matière de droits de
l'animal
5 la première on peut parler de prémices
de la protection de l'animal c'est 1850
avec la loi grammont que je résumerais
en cette phrase cacher cette souffrance
que je ne saurais voir
grammond était un général député qui ne
supportait plus de voir la souffrance
des animaux dans la rue et notamment des
chevaux parce qu'en 1850 il y avait
encore beaucoup de chevaux dans la rue
et en fait cette loi
eh bien elle à sanctionner d'une simple
contravention
les mauvais traitements sur animaux mais
à la condition qu'ils aient été commis
en public c'est à dire que vous pouviez
continuer de maltraité un animal dans
votre garage
mais en public c'était pas possible et
en fait qu'est-ce qu'elle protège cette
loi elle protège pas les animaux
directement elle protège la sensibilité
humaine mise à rude épreuve devant le
spectacle de la souffrance des animaux
il faudra attendre un siècle deuxième
étape 1959 pour que cette loi soit
abrogée et remplacée par une autre loi
qui en fait va cette fois considérer que
et bien on ne peut pas maltraiter les
animaux également dans la sphère privée
c'est à dire qu'en fait pour la première
fois on va considérer que les animaux
ont un intérêt propre à ne pas souffrir
troisième étape 1963 qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en 1963 bien pour l'instant
c'était simplement des contraventions
et bien en 1963 la loi va créer un délit
le délit d'actes de cruauté sur animaux
pour vous donner juste un ordre d'idée
un excès de vitesse c'est une
contravention tuer un animal sans le
faire souffrir
c'est une contravention voler c'est un
délit commettre un acte de cruauté sur
un animal c'est un délit quatrième étape
1976 pour la première fois la loi a
reconnu la sensibilité de l'animal et
cette sensibilité de l'animal elle a été
intégrée au code rural sous l'article l
214 1 l214 vous dit peut-être quelque
chose
et qu'est ce qui nous dit cet article eh
bien il dit que les animaux étant des
êtres vivants sensible leur propriétaire
doit les maintenir dans des conditions
respectant leurs impératifs biologiques
les impératifs biologiques de leur
espèce
la cinquième étape la plus importante
fin qui est la plus proche de nous c'est
et c'est donc au tour du code civil
d'avoir reconnu que les animaux sont des
êtres vivants doux et de sensibilité
alors la question qu'on se pose
effectivement c'est depuis 2015 puisque
les animaux sont des êtres vivants
sensible ça a dû changer
considérablement leur sort bah non
ben non ça n'a pas changé grand chose
pourquoi et bien parce que le code civil
il considère toujours les a que les
animaux sont des choses je vous explique
les règles de protection des animaux en
fait elle son entrepôt centre et c'est à
dire que c'est l'être humain qui est
toujours le référent et le code civil ne
voit les animaux domestiques comme une
chose appartenant à l'homme et en 1804
et toujours aujourd'hui en fait et bien
ce fameux code civil
il n'a que deux catégories à 3 2
les personnes
vous moi et les choses et dans les
choses ya les modes et les immeubles les
personnes sont des sujets de droit et ce
dès leur naissance un bébé qui vient de
naître est un sujet de droit il avait
droit
les sujets de droit les personnes donc
ont même des droits fondamentaux comme
par exemple ne pas être torturé ne pas
être détenu de manière arbitraire en
france et dans beaucoup de pays et bien
les animaux sont toujours dans la
catégorie des choses alors effectivement
ce sont allés dire des choses sensibles
ils sont toujours là quatre dans la
catégorie des choses ce sont donc des
objets de droit et des objets de droit
ils n'ont pas de droits alors ils ont
droit à une protection dans certains cas
mais n'ont pas de droit et surtout on
peut se les approprier il existe un
second courant beaucoup plus favorable
aux animaux qui considèrent en fait que
les animaux sont des sujets de droit et
qu'ils ont des droits et ce courant se
divisent lui-même en deux sous
catégories alors le droit les courants
les sous-courants les catégories les
sous-catégories l'adorent sa première
sous catégories les animaux doivent être
intégrés la catégorie des personnes donc
on en a les choses et les personnes
parce que les animaux sont des personnes
enseignants et non mais en france les
sociétés sont des personnes morales en
inde récemment on a accordé la
personnalité juridique à des fleuves et
même à des glaciers alors pourquoi on
accorderait pas des animaux alors ce
courant qui est le plus favorable c'est
un courant c'est le courant qui est le
plus minoritaire
ce bond sous courants ou second sous
catégories on va extraire les animaux de
la catégorie des choses et on va créer
une nouvelle catégorie celle des animaux
on aurait donc les choses les personnes
et les animaux et bien cette troisième
catégorie elle existe déjà dans de
nombreux pays européens pour ne citer
que la suisse l'allemagne la belgique
très récemment
mais en france non cette troisième
catégorie n'existe pas et donc on peut
dire que en fait en matière de
protection et mina animal la france est
très en retard est très en retard
sur le plan de droits de l'animal il ya
quand même une protection qui existent
mais cette protection
elle n'est pas la même pour tous les
animaux plus les animaux sont proches de
nous notamment son plan affectif et bien
plus la protection est forte
al'inverse que les animaux sont éloignés
de nous comme les animaux sauvages les
poissons est bien moins ils sont
protégés
pourquoi parce qu'il ne nous ressemble
pas parce qu'ils vivent loin de nous
parce qu'ils vivent à l'abri de nos
regards et l'adase loin des yeux loin du
coeur prend ici toute sa signification
ne croyait pas alors en fait cette cette
différence de traitement est bien va
conduire les êtres humains à faire des
catégories en fonction de l'utilité pour
l'homme et c'est ainsi que le sort que
l'homme que la justice humaine accorde
aux animaux ne va pas être le même
en fonction de leur catégorisation donc
on a les animaux de compagnie il faut
être inscrit sur une istres les en
france on a les chats les siens les
poissons rouges
les nac les cochons d'inde et puis
d'ailleurs on ne peut pas les manger
quand on est inscrit sur les animaux de
compagnie ensuite vous avez les animaux
domestiques ou vivant en captivité puis
ensuite les animaux sauvages et la joute
donne en mille il ya des sous catégories
mais je vais vous en faire grâce
imaginez
imaginez un instant que vous soyez un
petit lapin nain de compagnie annonce
trop rapide excusez-moi excusé pour ses
sorties
voilà imaginez que vous soyez donc je
recommence
imaginez que vous soyez un petit lapin
de compagnie eh bien vous avez gagné le
gros lot bah oui parce que vous êtes
considéré comme un être vivant sensible
et votre propriétaire n'a pas le droit
ni de vous faire de mal ni de vous tuer
et même certains humains vont vous
considérez vous faites partie de leur
famille
si votre propriétaire vous tue
proprement sans vous faire souffrir
avant c'est une contravention et il
encourt une peine d'amendé pouvant aller
jusqu'à 750 euros si votre propriétaire
commet des actes de cruauté sur vous des
actes les torts de torture avant de vous
tuer ou même si vous vous en réchapper
eh bien cette fois ci s'il est poursuivi
c'est un délit il encourt une peine
d'emprisonnement qui peut aller jusqu'à
deux ans ferme et l'amande peut aller
jusqu'à 30000 euros
imaginez que vous soyez à lapins de
garenne vivent en liberté
d'accord et bien pas de chance parce que
vous n'avez pas le statut d'être vivant
sensible
nan nan nan parce que vous êtes en reste
plus c'est à dire que vous n'appartenez
à personne donc ce n'est pas pour vous
n'êtes pas protégé ni par le code civil
ni par le code pénal
imaginez que vous soyez un lapin de
laboratoire alors comme vous êtes tenu
en captivité
eh bien vous êtes considéré comme un
animal vivant sensible souhaite pourtant
même si vous échapper au shampooing dans
les yeux et au rouge à lèvres sur l'anus
depuis une directive européenne de 2013
qui interdit en principe que l'on teste
des produits cosmétiques sur vous eh
bien on peut continuer de tester toutes
sortes de produits les produits
d'entretien sur vous on peut vous brûlez
avec dépôt de corrosif on peut vous
gaver d'antidépresseurs on peut vous on
peut vous en êtes vous là on peut vous
faire tout ce qu'on veut
imaginez que vous soyez un lapin angora
et bien votre magnifique toise on va
vous falloir de terribles souffrances
parce que on va vous attachez les quatre
pattes
et puis on va vous arracher les poils
vivent sans anesthésie à vif vous
laissant la peau la peau meurtri et puis
on va vous remettre dans votre cage on
va attendre que vos poils repoussent et
puis on recommencera deux trois quatre
fois et puis vous finirez dans une benne
à ordures
imaginez regardait pas la photo j'étais
censé avoir un noir la du noir pour vous
nous l'a donc voilà imaginez que vous
soyez un lapin élevé pour être mangé
comme 99% des lapins de consommation je
dis bien 99% et bien vous allez vivre
dans des cages les uns sur les autres on
pourrait même pas bougé même pas bouger
vous serez souvent blessé parfois même
votre vie compte si peu que vous
terminerez vivent dans une fosse à
lisier
et puis à l'âge de six mois
oui six mois maximum bien après avoir
passé de longues heures dans un camion
les uns sur les autres on va vous
terminerez votre vie suspendue par les
deux pattes arrière qui saigne et
parfois même en pleine conscience
comment expliquer endroit une telle
incohérence
comment expliquer juridiquement et même
moralement un tel paradoxe c'est à dire
d'un côté des animaux dont on reconnaît
l'existence la sensibilité et puis d'un
autre côté ces mêmes animaux à qui l'on
nie l'existence et toutes sensibilités
l'année man machine est toujours présent
parce qu'en fait l'être humain partir le
moment où il exploite un animal est bien
le considère toujours comme une machine
donc les vaches laitières basse et des
machines à l'est les poules pondeuses
les machines à eux
l'animal est un simple produit un
produit alimentaire introduit
vestimentaire un produits décoratifs un
produit de loisir
et puis lorsqu'il n'est plus assez
rentable plus assez de lait plus assez
de l'aisne le ac2a il finit sa courte
vie dans un abattoir de la même manière
que les animaux qui ont été levés direct
pour leur viande pour terminer sur une
note un petit peu plus optimiste je vais
vous raconter une histoire
je vais vous raconter l'histoire de
cécilia cécilia a été détenu dans une
prison argentine pendant de très longues
années dans des conditions de détention
déplorables
une association d'avocats argentin a
saisi la justice argentine faisant
valoir que les conditions de détention
de cécilia était préjudiciable pour sa
santé tant morale que physique et
surtout qu'elle était détenu de manière
illégale et arbitraire
ah oui j'ai oublié de vous préciser
quelque chose
l'association qui a saisi la justice
argentine c'est une association
d'avocats du défense de droits de
l'animal et cécilia je vous la présente
c'est un chimpanzé est bien le juge qui
a été saisi de la faire il a considéré
que cécilia n'était pas un objet de
droit que c'était un sujet de droit et
l'a ordonné sa libération et le 5 avril
cécilia elle a été remise en liberté
dans on dans une réserve naturelle au
brésil alors ce jugement il est
historique il est historique parce que
c'est la première fois que l'on
considère qu'un animal est une personne
et surtout qu'on lui accorde le droit
fondamental de ne pas être enfermé de
manière arbitraire alors à la manière de
lamartine qui disait on n'a pas de coeur
l'un pour l'animal l'autre pour l'homme
on a du coeur
on en a pas je dirais il n'y a pas de
justice il y a une aura pas deux
justices une pour l'homme et une autre
pour l'animal il ya une justice où il
n'y en a pas
[Applaudissements]